see this crazy [ __ ] they're talking
about Conor McGregor fighting Floyd
Mayweather with no shoes on in an MMA
cage with MMA gloves you can clinch but
no takedowns no knees no elbows no kicks
no submissions but the clinch can clinch
you can fight from the clinch yeah well
you know Mayweather's is an animal that
also yeah yeah but still one kick be
legal it would end it if he had kicks
that would be the difference that's it
but but Connor even fighting from the
clinch you could tie him up you could
tie him up and hold on to him and hit
him like Randy Couture style you
remember when Shane Carwin fought Frank
Mir and tied him up and just obliterated
him with uppercuts just a monster but
then again he chooses to stand there I
don't think that maybe what is gonna
choose to stand there if you get out he
pops out he needs to well there's no
need it's not like he pulls him to the
knee it gets needed in the face you see
what I mean because he can clinch with
him if he can clinch with them and
they're standing on the outside and
Connor can grab ahold of them how's
Mayweather gonna shake him off he's not
going to like if Connor decides to just
wrap a hold of one of his arms just get
him in an over hook and just start
punching him in the face what Floyd's
[ __ ] his whole thing is boxing his
whole thing is boxing little buddies his
shoulder rolls moves he's not gonna be
able to stop Connor from grabbing him
Connors a bigger stronger guy if he
grabs Floyd by the back of the neck and
holds him in place it punches him in the
face
Floyd's [ __ ] I don't think he
understands when you say the clinch is
okay if you could strike from the clinch
he's [ __ ] I'll put my money on Connor
all day if he can strike from the clinch
now if they just have MMA fight with
boxing gloves or a boxing fight with MMA
gloves rather that is a different thing
that's a different animal I think
Floyd's just so much better than that's
what I thought that Joe meant no no no I
mean clinching the what what I read the
only difference they're not gonna let
him kick they're not gonna let him punch
knock on them elbow or knee or takedown
or submissions but they'll let him
clinch and punch from the clinch just
that
yeah that's a game-changer just out
alone yeah I know I don't know I'm gonna
have to see that because you know
Floyd's gonna know they're gonna work on
that as well he's going to work on those
new fans it's an incredible athlete I
mean there's only a few things this is
not like he's gonna have to learn the
whole game
yeah but holding on to someone and
punching them is such a different it's
just a completely different chapter yeah
but as soon as you hold on to somebody I
mean she didn't capacitate at your own
arm as well you don't have the defense
there as well so right maybe I can start
attacking a male also that's a one-hand
fight it's literally ice hockey right if
you think about the graph but it's not
hitting each other sort of yeah yeah
yeah but smaller gloves Connor will have
more impact with his punches that's true
and he's so much used to much more used
to fighting from the clinch like that
where you can hold and hit at the same
time I mean I'm interested in that fight
what if our foot stomps you know what
that's what the last time I heard
somebody say do you always
super-effective footsteps give me one
fight they never got stopped with a foot
stomp never ever it's annoying it's
annoying that